all right the U.S women's national team
has been eliminated from the World Cup
after scoring zero goals the team lost
in the penalty kick round against low
rank Sweden this after a missed kick
from Team Superstar Megan rapinoz uh who
was a once proud recipient of the
presidential medal of freedom from Joe
Biden her poor performance earned this
strong rebuke from Donald Trump on Truth
social quote woke equals failure Megan
has been better known recently for
left-wing activism than her soccer
skills frequently kneeling during the
national anthem a huge proponent of
biological men competing in women's
sports and by the way we did check and
Megan has never once had to face a
biological man at the World Cup so maybe
she should Reserve judgment until she
knows uh what that's like for now she'll
just have to settle for knowing uh what
it's like to just lose big time here
with reaction author of a brand new book
just out today and it is the American
Playbook a guide to winning back the
country amazon.com hannity.com and
bookstores all around the country clay
Travis and the host of outkick's Tommy
laryn is fearless Tommy Lauren uh Tommy
I mean I wonder if she would think
differently clay told me today that I
went and looked it up I had not known
this that a Dallas a young man's team at
an academy somewhere in Dallas 15 years
old beat the national team five to two
and these are 15 year old boys versus a
profession almost like a professional
women's team
yeah exactly and when Megan rapino
talked about the proudest moment in her
career she talked about fighting for
equal pay for what I assume would be
women but then out of the other side of
her mouth she said she has no problem
with biological men competing against
women so which one is it Megan do you
want equality and fairness for women or
does it only come to your own paycheck
this woman is the epitome of selfish and
she made it really hard to root for the
United States and we all root for the
USA don't get me wrong even if it is
Megan rapino and others that decided to
kneel for the national anthem we still
root for this country it would be nice
though if those women who wear the USA
on their jerseys could love the country
as much as we do I don't think that's
too much to ask for Sean you know if you
look at the worst year in the NFL uh
clay Travis it was when we had the whole
Colin Kaepernick issue and Americans
were disgusted they did not want
politics in football and I understand
everyone's going woke and I understand
they think they inclusive but America
you're taking the most uniting moment a
common passion for a team a common
passion for a sport strangers
high-fiving each other in the stands and
you're ruining it by adding politics to
it if you want politics watch this show
every night you'll get your fill of it
you're 100 right and and that's why
Michael Jordan said Republicans buy
sneakers too Sean 15 year old boys in
Dallas just Dallas beat the U.S women's
soccer team that won the World Cup in
2019 5-2 couple things on this I was in
the crowd with my family in Vancouver
Canada in 2015 when Megan rapino and her
teammates won the first Women's World
Cup of this era this is one of the most
beloved teams of all time 2019 they go
off to France Donald Trump invites them
to the White House to celebrate their
back-to-back World Cup championships
they refuse to go 2023 Mega rupino wide
right on the kick who would have seen
that with that PK by the way Sean and I
bet you could have scored there I bet I
could have scored there I bet Tommy
could have scored there it ain't that
hard when you're that is not that if
you're the best woman in the world right
theoretically uh one of the best women
in the world and here's the other thing
on this they alienated everybody and
they didn't need to do it and if you get
to the point where so many people are
not upset this is the worst performing
Women's World Cup team of all time and
they wanted equality with the men
congratulations they've got equality
they both stunk and got kicked out in
the round of 16. you know if this ever
really takes hold every every bit of
progress that we've made with Title IX
and women's sports it goes away doesn't
it Tommy
oh it certainly does and I think it's
really rich for somebody like Megan who
is retiring to now say that she's okay
with the sport being absolutely ruined
and taken over by what could be in the
next several years many more biological
men who decide they've failed at their
own sport category and decide their
retirement plan is to play women's
sports so I think that's very rich but
here's another thing to this you can be
an activist you can be an athlete
activist we see it with LeBron and we
see it with many others across the NFL
the NBA the MLB you name it there are
activists but you have to be good and
that's where Megan uh lost and she fell
on her face there you have to be good if
you want to be cocky and indulgent and
unfortunately she missed the mark on
more than one thing and it was kind of
hard watching Riley Gaines have to deal
with Bill Maher that was a little rough
I think for everybody and being asked
very specific questions uh anyway thank
you both by the way clay congrats on the
book uh in bookstores now all around the
country the American Playbook how
conservatives can win back the country
yeah good idea thank you both hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else